Alright folks, how are you doing, I hope everybody is doing well and this is just a kind of like
a prep to get your mindset correct on what's coming in two days on the YouTube channel.
I want you to understand going forward that obviously you all are familiar with my moniker,
I've dubbed myself the demo baller and I've always talked through the medium of a demo
account for my own protection and I've had students come into my fold and question whether
or not it was something that could work in live accounts because they themselves couldn't
make it work in either a demo or paper trading because either they could not find it in themselves
to submit to the process and the time required for their own individual development or they
rushed and did things foolishly outside of the instructions that I provide in mentoring.
So there's a small faction of individuals on the internet that believe that these things
don't work in a live account and it's never really been an interest in me really to see
people fall over me and believe everything I say. I've challenged everyone to put the
things I teach to test, see if the things I'm teaching you are in fact in the marketplace,
do they deliver more times than not, does it provide you a way of finding consistency
over a week, not every single day perfection because I can't provide that, I don't even
trade perfectly like that. A new trader can, a new teacher can provide 100% accuracy.
But the way I teach and the way you'll see me mentoring on this channel in two days is I take
the yearners. All of you that are not trading yet or have tried trading and failed, you're
yearning to learn how to do this. So I'm teaching with that mindset. Now some of you
obviously may have already been with me and found some consistency and some of you are
doing exceedingly well and that's amazing, that's great and I'm thankful for all of that.
But this is really meant for, specifically, it's for my daughter. So I sat down and figured
I killed two birds with one stone and if I can show a simplistic way of going in using the things
that I teach, stripping it down to its chrome, okay, no bells and whistles, no advanced theories
or anything like that, what can I do to provide a model that my daughter could look at and say,
okay, there's not a lot of moving parts, it's real simple for me to decide what it is I want to do
and also when not to do something, okay. And some of you may already be completely upset with that
idea because you want me to come out here and lay an arsenal in your hands of high-tech weaponry.
It's been my experience that the highest form of analysis concepts that I've been teaching in my
personal mentorship many times creates exceptional traders, yes, but the majority of them,
and them being my students, they get bogged down in all of the content and it just creates
analysis paralysis and it's just too many things for them to decide because, like a kid in a candy
store, what do you eat first and while you're still chewing on the first thing, what are you
going to reach for next, okay. So if you don't have discipline and this is a personal responsibility
characteristic that all of you are going to have to really assume, okay, because I can lay the
things in your hands, but if you don't respect the fact that they have sharp edges, okay, or
if you use live ammunition before you're really properly trained, you could hurt yourself, okay.
So with that idea in mind, I'll be teaching a stripped down version of my concepts in a mentorship
style. So that way you can go through the process of learning how to do
a specific trading model and I'll keep things germane to that model, not try to bring in too
many things, and one of the approaches is to trade it with index futures, okay, and if you are
not interested in trading futures, that's fine, you can still trade
forex with these concepts as well, but I kind of like want to drive it with futures. I actually
began trading in 1992 as a commodity and futures trader and I moved away from grains and cattle and
gold, silver, crude oil, all those types of markets and moved into
the bond market, the third year treasury bond, and the S&P. So when that became my cup of tea,
if you will, I became a better trader intraday and I put down the pursuit of trying to be a long-term
position trader because I felt that that would be the best thing for me because at the time I was
working a job and had to balance all those things like working class individuals need to do, they
have to commute back and forth to work and those types of things. So I figured position trading
would be the thing for me and I found out that it didn't work for me, okay, so I liked the idea of
short-term trading, intraday trading, it made sense to me because I can make quick decisions.
That may not be your style of trading. I will teach you how to apply the things I'm going to teach
on the YouTube channel, how you can scale that up into any time frames. That way there's no excuse
for you not to be able to use the information to at least better your understanding in price action.
Okay, so here's my promises to you. I promise you, you're going to learn things that absolutely
repeat a lot. You are not going to be perfect. It's not my goal to make you a perfect trader.
It's not my goal to make you a perfect analyst. My goal is to improve your understanding about
price action, how price is delivered, and how to read the bias on an intraday basis, a daily basis,
and hopefully over a short-term period of time you can find setups that repeat and they have common
characteristics that are very similar but they won't be identical. They won't be carbon copies
but you'll see similarities that to know and trust that this is a setup that you are familiar
with. Because you are all being viewed as yearners, you are all yearning to learn how to do this.
There's three stages in this YouTube mentorship. I'm treating you all as green horns. You're just
yearning to do this. A lot of you that begin this YouTube mentorship will not complete it because
you're going to get frustrated because you want something else or an alternative way of
me teaching it to you. I'm not going to take suggestions from anybody on how to teach it
differently. This is the way I'm going to teach it. It will not be setups given to you for trades
but I will take your attention before the fact and draw them out on a chart where I want you to
study, where price will likely draw to next. Using the things I teach you conceptually,
it's your job to study that. Do not look at that as a trade setup. Do not look at that as
an enticement to take a live trade. It's my intention to take the yearners that want to learn
how to do this through a process of becoming structured learners. You're going from yearning
to learning and hopefully at your discretion and timing you'll become an earner. You're an earner,
learner, earner. Those three stages are what I'm going to take you through. It's not going to be
an entire year mentorship. I'm only going to do probably three or four months but before we
get into it I want you to know that I will not be providing any content to the YouTube channel or
my own personal mentorship during the month of March. March 2022 I will not be doing anything.
I'll be on vacation and we're going to be doing several road trips so I will not be working for
you. If you can accept that then I think over the next coming months it should be rather entertaining
and interesting for you as a student. So you're looking at this screen here and one of the things
I promised I would do in 2022 is to show you how some of these concepts would work in an environment
outside of a demo account. I've always used the moniker demo baller because that's my name. I
gave myself that to kind of like champion the idea that I'm teaching through a demo but if
I can teach you through a demo and things are repeating you can see your charts okay whether
it's a live platform or if it's a demo you're seeing the things that I teach and if you've
been fortunate enough to be in my presence when I'm calling it beforehand it's very rewarding
and you all on YouTube will have those experiences as well but the main thing is for you not to grow
a dependency on me pointing to everything before it happens because if you do that or if you have
that mindset going in it's going to stunt your growth and in fact it's going to create a barrier
for you because it'll create a codependency state of mind and I don't want that. I try to foster a
independent mindset where you're independently coming to the decisions on your own it's that
way the results are yours if it's success you own it if you failed you own that too. I can't
cosine for your failure and some of you absolutely will fail. I've said this many times openly and
every time I've been asked in 2016 I started a paid mentorship and I have students from that
time period that are still trying to find their way and they cannot make these things work for
themselves. I have other students from 2016 that are absolutely mind-blowing results and I have
students from a mentorship group that was the final class in 2021. I'm not taking new enrollments
don't ask. That group I have traders that are doing very well as well so it's not a shortcoming
on what is there being taught. It's just an individual unique experience that you have to
grow and go through and I can't speed it up for you any more than I already done. So I'm optimistic
but I'm a realist. I know some of you simply will not do the things I ask you to do. You will not do
them effectively and you'll try to shortcut certain things and you'll think that you don't
need to do this and don't do that and your results will be reduced because of that. So if I suggest
things to you drills homework things to study do your best to participate in that okay and
even if you can't do it live you know there's other ways to go through and look at it. It's
not the same as seeing it live but it's the best you can do because some of you have businesses
some of you have school jobs okay let's be real and you may have family things that keep you also
from being able to watch live data in the times I'm asking you to do it. I'm not going to jump
through hoops. I'm not going to do acrobatics to make it you know feasible for every single one of
you okay. It's unrealistic for you any of you to have that expectation of me because I don't need
to be doing this. I love doing it I'm looking forward to doing it but I want to make sure all
of you have the right mindset okay. So in 2022 I promised that you would see how these concepts work
in an environment outside of a demo account and what would that mean? Well it would mean not well
not an MT4 platform because years ago it's been shown how frauds and fakes can use that platform
to pretend that they're profitable that they can find setups and that their trading is amazing
and they can go in and edit their trades after the fact after the market's already moved.
Well I've already proven that I don't do those types of things and I went to TradingView
and that was the platform that I asked my community I said which which platform should I use if I'm
going away from MT4 I want to go to a platform that's reputable so I teach and you'll see me
teaching through TradingView so that's the medium that we use. It's familiar to me because I'm
teaching mentorship students through that but if that's not your platform of choice you're just
going to have to get used to me teaching through that medium because I'm not going to do something
in addition to okay. But for a live account I felt that TD Ameritrade is very reputable
and that it is regulated by the Common Future Trading Commission and all of the other governing
bodies. I cannot rig this to make it look like I'm smarter okay I can't go back in and change
a trade I can't fix it okay I can't add lipstick to it okay it either is or isn't
a profitable trade okay it's as simple as that. TD Ameritrade uses the margins that are accepted
and established in the industry and some of you may not be able to trade a market because of margin
don't let that be a hindrance I'll show you how to work around that in other platforms. While I
don't personally use an MT4 account for teaching or trading live funds or anything like that
I'm confident that students that are trying to learn how to do this they can still use MT4 or MT5
or any other platform for that matter. I as an educator though moved away from those platforms
because they can be gained okay in other words they can be used to fraud and fake results okay
so in trading view you've seen examples after examples of me going in recording an entry
calling the moves as it happens without the replay button because replay doesn't let you do
trade entries okay and replay only shows you a completed candlestick it doesn't show you the
generation of the open all the price action up and down to the close of every individual candlestick
so I've had a lot of folks over the years ask me to show live account show live account show live
account and one of the things that kept me from wanting to do it is because if I show results of
any kind right away and this is how I viewed it too as a developing student in the 1990s
that made me feel like I'm never going to get it because their results were
way above what I could do as a learning developing student I had no idea what I was doing in 1992
but to see people say yeah I made fifty thousand dollars in the soybean market
okay or I made eighty thousand dollars in coffee well
that to me was a very huge mountain decline like I have to do that
it just it felt impossible but I also didn't want to give results that were so low end
that it didn't inspire an interest in having people want to learn it so because this business
is extremely unique and personal it's both the easiest thing you'll ever do and sometimes
for many of you is the most impossible thing to be successful at and that sounds like a
knocking moron it sounds like double talk and it is but it isn't how's that for a rib
you can't appreciate how difficult it is until you start trading with live funds
but before you start trading with live funds and you're in the consistently
profitable demo trading stage you feel like you could do anything but something magical happens
when you go into a live account where now suddenly every little tick means something to you
because it means success or failure on an individual basis whereas if you lose on a
demo account you didn't really lose anything you can take another demo trade but with live
account trading you have to deal with that drawdown and that loss and making money in an
account is sometimes worse than losing money because it'll make you feel like you want another
taste of that and it creates opportunities for you to go in and over trade and or over leverage
and both of those things we'll talk about in the youtube mentorship how to avoid some of those
things but it's up to you to avoid them okay and it takes a lot of ownership personally and the
responsibility that is required to do this is paramount okay you cannot have anybody else
take responsibility for your actions it's your actions and if you do well you earned it if you
don't do well you hate have you have to eat it okay it's the way it is and too many people are
weak-minded in this world that they will never become successful traders no matter who teaches
them what whatever thing they use they're going to be a failure okay that's just the way it is
and there's no way around that i can't fix and improve everyone's shortcomings i have my own
personal issues that i fight and wrestle with internally and it's not easy like i'm obsessively
compulsive and i have i have adv it's all these things okay that make it difficult for me and i'm
bipolar i have a lot of mental barriers but if i can sit down and frame out an idea that repeats
at least once a week i'm confident that those individuals out there that are like me or without
these barriers can do it as well that's my personal belief it doesn't make it fact it doesn't make it
true it just means that that's my belief and i've seen case studies in my own students where
that's true it's a transferable skill but the skill must be honed by you the student
so anyway i promised i would show some results in 2022 outside of a demo account so i used
td ameritrade but years ago i was asked to show a regulated broker non-mt4
and i felt that td ameritrade was a better choice outside of you know the standard
forex account brokers because with td ameritrade you can trade forex you can trade futures you can
trade commodities stocks options you can bonds everything out there you can trade it okay so
eventually over time if you do become successful when you're profitable you want to go with a
broker that allows you to have access to all those vehicles because there's certain times of the year
certain asset classes just aren't going to do very well but others will and this type of broker
and i'm not repping td ameritrade i don't get anything for it i'm not introducing broker
i'm just saying that when i'm showing results in an account that is not demo this is the broker
that i deposited funds with so that way we know what i'm saying here i'm not telling you to go
here and trade okay i have only traded a few trades with this broker but i can tell you their
fills are immediate their confirmations are solid i haven't had any problems technically it's just
i'm fumbling with the layouts the way things are
made available to me because it's just like anything else when i'm transitions from mt4
teaching from that being very comfortable with that going into
trading view it's very cumbersome and i'm still clumsy with it when i'm teaching and
i'm finding it a little bit cumbersome here as well because i just don't know where they have
certain things i don't know how to make the charts scalable as fast as i want them to be
and like i'm used to doing it with trade station or trading view or mt4 so it's just a learning
process but it doesn't change the fact that if you know how to trade then the trades are easy
so i keep everything very simple you know i use limits and markets to get in and i just collapse
the trade when it gets to a target of my choice so that's all i'm showing you here today it's
just to show you that the things i'm going to be showing you are applicable on paper
and in demo and the same logic is used here and while this is not a lot of money it's only
twenty three thousand six hundred ninety four dollars and eleven cents it's not
something to brag about let's just put it that way but it's something that's not demo it's something
that won't stay at that level and my objective is to teach conceptually a hypothetical income
based strategy okay it's not a trying to beat the world cup okay it's not trying to do better
trying to do better than every instagram trader out there it's just trying to teach how someone
can take another opportunity and hopefully in the best case scenario and i can't guarantee or
promise it to you but i'm going to certainly do my best to do what i know and how i can teach it so
that way you can be at least inspired to make an attempt to try okay and because i believe that
things are about to get really really hard for everyone financially and without going in great
detail just look around the world and you know what i'm talking about but this is the e-mini
s&p march delivery contract for 2022 okay and it's a two-minute chart and i want you to see
the put inventory here this is a short it took and the cover was here
and another one here small little scalp
in here and then over here i'm showing you so that way you can see there was no other
trades after that short or two shorts rather and then today i slept in
and i just want to have something in addition to what i already have here
this is kind of like one of the setups that you're going to learn in the mentorship
where is the entries here
and the exits here okay not a lot of handles okay handle would be like 4567 to 4568
so that's four ticks or one full handle in this market it's fifty dollars per handle or per four
ticks so every one tick is twelve dollars and fifty cents above this high is buy stops and i
was targeting that here running into that okay so very very simple strategy optimal trade entry
you don't need to get in at this level here okay i'm going to teach you how to have forgiving
entries you don't need to be highly precise about your entries but you need to be precise
about the directional bias and where it's going okay where's price reaching for and that's kind
of like what i'm showing you in this mentorship on the youtube channel so if i have at least
giving you the opportunity to find setups conceptually if that's the case then
over time if you submit yourself to it you'll find more setups than you'd ever imagine
because they're there a lot in excess on these lower time frames so in a nutshell what am i
saying here i'm saying that if you can learn how to take 25 handles okay if you can take 25 handles
out of a market like the e-mini s&p you may not have the margin 12 13 000 or whatever it is to
trade one contract of this market you don't need to have that you can trade the micros and while
you're not making 50 dollars per handle on e-mini s&p you're making five dollars per handle you can
still graduate over time and build that up and it's not a lot of initial margin that's required
to do that or if you're outside the us you can trade a cft and trade the us 500 market through
like an mt4 account and again i'm just going to touch on that i'm not suggesting that you
should especially those individuals in the states because it's actually illegal for you to trade
that because it doesn't go through a regulated exchange exchange like a futures market would
so that makes it illegal for us traders to do that so we have to in the us trade through the
futures market and they have been nice enough to provide micro accounts or vehicles like the
e-mini s&p and the nasdaq they have micro accounts so whatever the multiplier would be on the
regular mini it's just reduced to a smaller level in terms of margin and tick value and i'll cover
all that stuff it's i've made it very very simple or at least that's been the goal i'm having going
into this and make it very very simple for all of you to look at it say okay i don't have to have
1000 moving parts i can go in and simply look at things that make sense and if you can visually
understand what it is i'm teaching you'll see that it doesn't require a lot of chart graffiti
okay things that are very distracting do you look at this chart here and see a lot of things that
would be mysterious no very simple little things i'll draw a line to highlight a level that i want
to see breached okay and a level where i want to see it reach up into and that's the basis of
understanding how the markets work within a liquid matrix you have buy side and sell side
and once you have that understanding and i'll teach some of those things in the mentorship
you'll be able to find setups that repeat at least one good setup a week but if you can find 25
handles a week in the e-mini market you can do very very well at that very very well you don't
need to hit home runs and here's my inspiration to you in closing if we're looking at a market
that provides us setups and let's just say your mortgage or your rent is say 1500 it may not be
that much it may be actually more than that but i'm just gonna say let's just say it's 1500
what happens if you can earn enough to make 50 or all of that a month going forward
would that not be beneficial to you that's the mindset i want you to have or let's say you have
a car money in your car payment in your car insurance if you could find a way to have that
money come to you by your own speculation over time not right away i'm not suggesting all of
you are going to be able to do this in the same year but over time if you submit to the process
i outline for you my belief is my personal belief my honest opinion is i believe that it is possible
now anyone can say oh anything's possible but i believe the things i'm going to show you are
things that you'll be able to spot on your own now i'm going to coach you throughout the coming
months showing you where certain things may deliver but i don't want you to feel like you need that
so i'll teach you how to anticipate certain things on your own and then you check yourself
with the things i reveal or do a review with and my belief is that you'll be better
at reading price when i'm done doing this youtube mentorship and again i don't think i'm going to
be doing more than four months and that four months is actually including the month of march
where nothing nothing's getting uploaded nothing in my private mentorship or on youtube so i will be
vacationing that entire month so i'll be doing those things during the month of march and in
april i'll return back to the mentor that i am in my private mentorship and i'll return back to
the delivery of the lessons on the youtube channel so what does the schedule look like
for this mentorship on youtube obviously friday will be your first episode and then it'll be a
tuesday and thursday upload there will be assignments and pdf files provided for
your learning throughout the week i'm not promising any specific schedule on that but you'll be able
to see them if you go to my community tab i'll provide a way for you to get to the information
and download it and i think that if you submit to this you'll be far better than you are right
now about reading price expecting certain things to deliver and you'll find that it's not as
challenging when you have a good mentor and you have sound logic and it's not over complicated
and that's my goal going in and i'll talk to you on friday be safe